he knows he's not lying he knows every
bit of information about every tile on
the floor even events that have happened
a rape happened here it's the exact spot
yeah this is where people die like I
know there was a shootout here this guy
jumped off the roof of the Hyatt that he
landed right here and these are things
that are real now this is where you find
the ghosts Gus you know there's Gus the
ghost he wasn't really well what's that
story Gus that goes you don't know Gus
Oh guys Gus is a ghost that haunts the
comedy stories our body
oh he's friends with you know you evil
why would you say he's your buddy he's
broken he's broke a guy's spine Pete
gray he broke his spine bro what okay so
it's not like Casper this is like no
does not Casper like Gus I told you okay
yeah Casper's in West Hollywood whoo
dreamy no arm you know their comedy
store in the 50s used to be called Syros
it was a nightclub
it was mob Ron apparently this guy named
Gus who was a mafia guy he got killed
there and then his ghost haunts the
comedy store and when Carla beau and Sam
Kinison they were called the Houston
boys and Bill Hicks as well when they
came down from Houston to the Comedy
Store Sam and Karl didn't have any money
so they slept on the main room stage
they would sneak in the club and sleep
there and Carl told me personally that
one night he was awoken to Sam being
levitated by his ankle upside down off
the ground of the on the main stage
while he was sleeping and he was dropped
and Carl told me about Gus and then
Blake Clark who was another guy from the
80s
he used to never go down to the cellar
because he saw Gus there a couple times
and then what disgust look like he's got
a top hat a yellow suit top hat
voiceless what era 50s another 50 yeah
no so I know but the top hat and
it was like not a top hat not top it was
just like a mafia hat
oh yeah short one not at the Abe Lincoln
and then um there was this guy named
Pete gray who was a comic there in the
90s he was a doorman and he was in the
belly room and he did a good spot and he
was walking down the the UM you know the
green room and then the showroom there's
a little hallway there you know the
hallway and he was levitated his heads
hit the ceiling and he broke his spine
what it ghosts have against Pete Pete
was shifty and then me and Johnny
Sanchez saw um Gus one night we had a
gig in Bakersfield this is in the late
90s and I left my truck in the parking
lot and then say Johnny drove us to the
gig we came back it was like 4:00 in the
morning and then we both were talking
and then we looked up I don't know why
but at the top window and we saw a man
up there his face his hands on the glass
but had no face and a top hat and he was
just peeking down at us and then we
looked at each other we screamed we
looked back up he was gone and then that
was Gus yeah Johnny and I we'll both
talk about it yeah yeah we both saw it
why you why you questioning so do you
like fully believe in ghosts
no I don't believe them at all well I
believe in that is what just Gus it's
like this laundry Gus is the only one oh
my god what he goes yeah hey here's
another thing that people don't know
that Mitzi's office you know do the 25
years I've lived there I mean work there
I've never seen her I know where the
office is I know where the door is
it's it is a door and there's a st.
stained-glass kind of window thing so
you can like look at certain glasses and
look into the room but apparently
they've never I haven't opened it in
like almost 30 years because there's not
gasa another entity in there that's like
levitates
bones and books and yeah and and she she
hired an exorcist every year apparently
for many years to clean the room and
here's the craziest story I saw this
thing I saw I mean I don't even talked
about this right the people in the
cloaks no I never talked about the
cloaks no I feel like so scared right
why would a ghost or he's like alright
this is the scariest she did the lights
so one night at like 2:00 3:00 in the
morning I was still there hanging out
and I'm like why come we're not closing
up and I in the end one of the managers
there just named guy named Don
Richardson he said yo man there's
something going on he's black oh it's
like a seance
I got it with the yeah yeah Sam yeah
yeah you got the oh man you guys young
man what's that black personal agent no
I'm kidding I'm so so racist I'm sorry
because hey man hey man hey buddy we
close up right now because uh there's
something going on upstairs so um he
goes but don't go up there and I go why
but there's a back way to sneak up so I
snuck up there and that back door was
open and I crawled and to look to see
what was going on in there and there was
like 12 people in there wearing cloaks
with it with the hood and everything
like it was candles around and they were
chanting you say cloaks with the hood
like a cake no no what color clothes no
no they're more like um wizard [ __ ] oh
yeah purpley cloak like yeah they're not
was it like a sexual thing like was it
eyes wide shut or was it more like they
were trying to conjure a spirit well no
it was they were it was 12 people trying
to conjure Andy Kaufman Oh
because when I I stayed there that night
to see who can walk down being a couple
of comics and one of them was Lily
Tomlin
I love her and the other one was Bob
zmuda Andy's best friend so do you think
that if we were to ask Lily Tomlin
point-blank have you ever tried to bring
Andy Kaufman spirit to the present world
she would say yes I did I think she
could she would yeah that because even
it like that makes it infinitely cooler
in my book and I believe that that that
they did contact him so you believe in
that stuff so you believe in just one
ghost named Gus yeah that lives in this
world all the others live in another
world and you got to bring him back
well I I can only I can only attest to
Gus and then in when I was in high
school my brother and I you know our
house was haunted the half remember my
brother and I were both possessed you
guys also build another part of the
house for you guys stayed in they built
another in extension to the house yeah
yeah my point is is that so I can only
you know confirm that the Rancho
Bernardo house where I lived and Gus
because of the only two entities that
I've encountered now after if there are
other entities and I encounter them then
I will you know pay a homage to them
that the right word I like the immersion
homage and I will you know I will bow
and I will go welcome to this realm you
know just don't possess me please or
stigmata me because I don't want it I
already have liver spots on my face well
thank you so you know so that place is
just if you're ever in LA tiger belly
fans and if you ever want to visit the
celeb king
[Music]